it had been many years since I'd last
seen him I wondered how he was doing I
found myself thinking about him on long
nights what if I was wrong what if I had
been blind
what if Pokemon were real it took me a
long time to track him down but after
three years I found him
you didn't see me well here I am
bees Master 64 again I've called every
single Pokemon except one the joyride I
don't the guy riders the Jew the jihad
rod the giraffes
you may be wondering why I'm wearing
this it's no water but an insider tip
told us the Beastmaster 64 tumblr blog
someone commented that don't gyrados
it's out there
you've me
have you seen the giraffes did you ride
it's over there
isn't over there she said she knew
exactly where it was I never felt so a
lad
we're closed boys ring close that they
calling my name
we smash their 64 I'm coming for you
this my bow the csgo loud how where's
your bookcase I but you can't afford
this the csgo Lada has set every record
there is except one
to catch the guardhouse
wait do you expect me to game this burg
what the [ __ ] is going to documentary it
this is a $5,000 camera and it's just I
don't want to be in the water what are
you [ __ ] magic Oh No let's go yeah
bro
all right what's your name documentary
man where I don't give a [ __ ] we're
going out right now I'm going to cook up
the time it is dawn coming
ah hurry up
I need you to get the water and we're
sinking what are you doing get the viola
cat it's time
get the boat we believe you get the bump
yet to poke a [ __ ] I'm gonna have to
send the poker [ __ ] come on poke [ __ ]
go Oh
don't tell me
we're gonna have to go out manually
I don't come back
seeing him dejected on that beach it was
in that moment that I knew everything he
had been searching for was real
the jeera dose was real and I had to see
it for myself this wasn't the end he had
to go back out there and I was going
with him
Now or Never
that comeback
cameraman is watering
Sammy one-take do you plead
come on they don't have a catchy Wow
you're wearing a life jacket beats Mouse
264 should I be wearing a life jacket oh
absolutely
swim you can't swim
wait I can't swim you know what the
worst leo dying is Tyra darts yeah that
was it
getting eaten by one we're getting close
now cameraman oh we gonna be legends we
got me [ __ ] leg there it is oh my god
oh my god cameraman it's been a pleasure
working by your side but once I go away
now we'll make it back
what do you mean going since we pick it
what we stop it you have the catcher
manual I have to catch it manually
you're right I will continue your legacy
after you're gone you made a believer
out of me I'm gonna download Pokemon go
ha ha ha oh my god
right now remember me cattlemen that the
me
ha
yeah
didn't make it
get it and make it
I see swallowed him and I didn't get the
guitar
or a [ __ ] [ __ ]
people don't understand it's dangerous
I'm going out again